à savoir un vrai talent pour le chant
pour les champs mais c'est pour ses
proches lui disent le contraire
ils disent que c'est pas vrai quand on
vient pas un petit cadeau offrir à rice
a là un petit voyage avec son mec en
séjour en europe
un petit séjour en europe c'est pour moi
là c'est cadeau voilà merci merci c'est
bon ça vaut le coup de venir très bien
et ben voilà mathieu riboulet te dire un
truc déjà je t'apprécie beaucoup je
regarde l'émission depuis des années des
votes
je sais que tu es un homme de défis oui
c'est vrai j'ai un défi pour toi ce soir
ou là ce soir a dit dubois
bien que je suis sur instagram j'ai un
blog mode moi c'est vrai et j'ai une
petite communauté qui naîtrait fidèles
d'ailleurs je les salue tous tous et
toutes
et devant ce soir je te lance ce défi de
me faire monter à 50 50 milles avant la
fin des mises et à combien ces possibles
attendait allez c'est parti et violences
ou des filles voilà cinquante mille sur
à 50 milles sur un stade c'est dur
twitter qui aurait dit oui sur un vide
mais on va essayer on va chez toi sur la
avec déjà vingt mille sur un stade ça
sera assez c'est normal je vous le dis
sur un stade c'est très dur de prendre
vie mais 50 un petit show à la fin quand
même chaud de quoi je parle shoah show
surprise un niveau bas je voulais avec
plaisir d'accord mais vous savez je t'ai
tient très bien et ben vas-y aller alors
en bon on va le mettre
on veut le mettre enceinte et comme ça
on va voir oui oui oui à l'épaule et il
ya enfin il est un petit show babilou
pas